on disait en début d'émission yes plus
Yvelines étudiant senior c'est un
dispositif du département et de l'agence
autonomie pour lutter contre l'isolement
des personnes âgées pour se faire des
visites de convivialité sont organisées
elles sont effectuées par des jeunes qui
ont un job rémunéré on disait tout à
l'heure avec vous Adrien à Bardin je
rappelle un chef de service prévention
et lien social à l'agence autonomique
l'été est une période délicate avec une
particulière attention même si le
dispositif est aujourd'hui déployé sur
toute l'année il y a plus c'est toute
l'année dans les Yvelines ouais
exactement le dispositif il fonctionne
toute l'année donc on peut y faire appel
toute l'année et ça c'est grâce à
l'engagement effectivement des CCAS et
des ça donc qui donc les salles les
services d'accompagnement d'aide à
domicile
communale d'action sociale qu'on a
l'habitude d'utiliser ces acronymes mais
c'est pas forcément
et donc ce sont eux effectivement qui
porte le dispositif et toute l'année du
coup on peut faire appel à ces étudiants
qui sont agents de convivi donc ça a été
créé en 2020 yes plus combien de
bénéficiaires aujourd'hui sur le
territoire des Yvelines alors oui le yes
plus existe depuis 2020 après c'est un
dispositif qui anciennement s'appelait
et qui a été créée en le lendemain de la
canicule donc en 2004 aujourd'hui c'est
à peu près 1800 seniors qui sont
accompagnés tous les mois en moyenne et
85 à peu près étudiant embauché en tant
qu'agent de convivialité qui rendent
visite au domicile des personnes
âgées et qui peuvent aussi passer des
appels de convivialité à ces personnes
selon les préférences toujours et s'il y
a un profil type de des personnes
accompagnées justement on parle de
personnes âgées c'est-à-dire de plus de
60 ans c'est ça oui alors le dispositif
il est ouvert à des personnes qui ont 60
ans et plus aujourd'hui le profil type
il est plutôt autour d'une personne qui
aurait 80 85 ans qui vit à son domicile
seul
et qui fait appel à des étudiants à ce
dispositif là pour recevoir des visites
pour pouvoir partager un moment de
convivialité des jeux des choses comme
ça et en moyenne sont aussi enfin pour
l'essentiel d'ailleurs ce sont plutôt
des femmes alors pourquoi c'est
essentiel justement de créer ces
interactions sociales c'est essentiel
pour leur bien-être on peut l'imaginer à
ces personnes âgées oui effectivement
parce que le la dynamique en tout cas
démographique du département des
Yvelines notamment mais c'est le cas
pour pour la France entière finalement
c'est qu'on observe aussi un
vieillissement de la population c'est
pas forcément c'est pas une mauvaise
chose bien au contraire mais par contre
ça doit s'accompagner des bons gestes
des bons des bons automatismes on va
dire et ce dispositif on est persuadé
oui qu'il y participe grandement parce
que prévenir la solitude de personnes
âgées à leur domicile c'est les garder
pleinement intégré dans la société dans
les échanges avec avec l'autre
l'extérieur et de pouvoir infiner aussi
prévenir la perte d'autonomie de ces
personnes là parce que c'est resté actif
c'est rester actif sur le plan physique
et sur le plan psychologique psychique
et ces personnes ont leurs proches assez
loin finalement c'est pour ça qu'ils
sont aussi qui ressentent cette solitude
on a des cas très différents finalement
on va avoir des personnes qui
effectivement n'ont pas forcément
d'aidants en proximité et qui ressentent
vraiment cette solitude au quotidien et
qui sont d'ailleurs enfin d'un point de
vue très objectif isolé ils ont peu ou
pas d'interactions quotidiennes d'autres
en revanche
ont des interactions régulières ont des
aidants à proximité mais de bénéficier
aussi du VS plus c'est d'avoir des
échanges avec des jeunes avec des gens
qu'on ne connaît pas forcément c'est de
créer aussi des liens qui sont
différents de ce qu'on a avec sa famille
ses proches ses amis et c'est ce qui
donne envie aussi aux personnes je pense
de faire appel à dispositif quels sont
leurs retours justement aux personnes
qui bénéficient de ce dispositif
aujourd'hui on a des très bons retours
même si au début c'est vrai que c'est
compliqué parfois de laisser entrer une
personne qu'on ne connaît pas chez soi
notamment un jeune il y a des regards
sur la jeunesse et au contraire sur la
les personnes âgées qui sont parfois un
peu difficiles à dépasser justement ce
dispositif il permet ça quoi on a des
retours sont très très positif avec des
des belles histoires en tout cas qui
perdurent bien au-delà du dispositif on
a des jeunes qui restent en contact par
téléphone ou qui rendent visites de
temps en temps à des personnes âgées qui
les ont visité il y a plusieurs mois
voire plusieurs années dans le cadre du
Yas plus Audrey à la jeunesse à Poissy
là on a parlé beaucoup des personnes
âgées en quoi ça peut être enrichissant
selon vous pour les jeunes d'aller à la
rencontre de ces personnes âgées de
favoriser finalement ce lien entre les
générations tout à fait de le sujet de
l'intergénération depuis la covid c'est
multiplier et justement le croisement
des histoires on en parle beaucoup de ce
qu'ils ont pu vivre aussi dans leur
jeunesse d'avoir aussi un échange comme
vous l'avez dit de recréer du lien c'est
primordial ne serait-ce que pour les
aînés et aussi pour les jeunes parce
qu'il y a aussi un suivi sur leur sur
leur perspective d'avenir aussi ça peut
être intéressant sur leurs échanges et
c'est vrai ce lien là je pense que comme
vous l'avez fait comme vous le faites et
c'est très bien il faut continuer à le
faire peut-être encore plus c'est voir
comment est-ce qu'on peut aussi aider à
valoriser ces personnes uniques qui
finalement en fait ils sont tellement
d'histoires à partager et à nous
apprendre donc bravo à vous en tout cas
oui faut continuer vous avez beaucoup de
jeunes qui sont candidats ou justement
vous êtes à la recherche constante de
jeunes pour effectuer ses visites alors
on est toujours à la recherche de
candidats parce que ça c'est c'est un
dispositif qui existe pour tout le
département des Yvelines le département
il est grand on a des besoins de toute
façon d'embaucher des agents de convier
il était partout et on a de plus en plus
de personnes aussi qui veulent faire
appel au dispositif
donc là pour le coup on parlera je pense
du recrutement par la suite mais
effectivement c'est vraiment quelque
chose aussi le dispositif je pense que
c'est important de le souligner on
l'accompagne aussi de toute une offre en
fait en matière de maintien du lien
social qui est porté par des
associations voilà qui sont qui existent
dans les Yvelines on a des choses comme
une lettre un sourire par exemple qui
permet de créer des correspondances des
échanges de lettres entre des jeunes et
des personnes âgées voire personne qui
sont accueillies en résidence on a un
partenariat par exemple avec l'ensemble
de générations qui permet d'accueillir
un étudiant chez soi à l'année de créer
aussi des échanges autour de ça donc il
y a beaucoup de choses aussi en qui
viennent en supplément de ce yes plus
alors pour terminer le recrutement
comment sont-ils recrutés comment
candidatés justement pour y plus alors
comment candidater aujourd'hui en fait
on a des offres pour devenir agent de
convivialité qui sont disponibles sur
toutes les plateformes de recrutement et
de voilà de transfert nos annonces sur
ces plateformes là les plus connues je
vais pas les cités mais mais c'est
possible de les retrouver sur ces
plateformes on peut aussi passer par le
site donc cette nouvelle plateforme que
vous évoquez
le site plus.fr et qui permet à la fois
de s'inscrire pour bénéficier du
programme sus en tant que personne âgée
mais aussi en tant qu'étudiant devenir
candidater et proposer sa candidature
pour devenir agent de convivialité donc
on peut candidater on peut inscrire sur
une personne âgée on le rappelle
dispositif gratuit pour les personnes
âgées c'est un dispositif qui est
gratuit ouais c'est très important de le
dire pour les personnes âgées c'est
entièrement financé par le département
des Yvelines
et c'est donc porté par l'agence
autonomie qui derrière opère ce
dispositif et qui est vraiment à
disposition aussi via un numéro vert via
voilà des échanges aussi possibles par
mail via cette plateforme au yes plus
tout à fait et via des des documents
papier qu'on peut remplir aussi et qui
sont disponibles dans les CCAS et les
services d'aide et d'accompagnement à
domicile qui sont partenaires dans le
cadre d'être venu en parler en plateau
je rappelle que vous êtes le chef de
service prévention et lien social pour
l'agence autonomie et on retrouve en
disait tout à l'heure toutes les
informations sur ce dispositif S+ sur le
site internet qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran merci encore d'avoir